jesse in the past seven battles you have
been faced with fierce competitors and
you've knocked them all out of this
competition and if you win today you
will match the most amount of money ever
earned in fortune fire history
fifty thousand dollars your competitor
has two gladiator forge titles of his
own oh
jesse in order to win the day you're
gonna have to beat this guy
kurt
my name is kurt i'm a two-time gladiator
of the forge now i get another chance at
beating jesse and then he can feel what
it's like to have a loss under his belt
this battle will consist of eight hours
of forging competition where you will
build one of these three blades from our
wall of gladiator weapons
today you need to build this
i hope it's not a dollar bra
the dalara
the deliver was a versatile weapon used
by the roman empire army in the first
century and beyond featuring a massive
axe head on one side and a sharp pick on
the other the versatile battle axe
doubled as a tool for soldiers who would
need to fell trees and clear brush
in the coliseum the labor's ability to
deliver deadly chops and lethal blows
against an enemy made it a favorite
weapon of the gladiators
bladesmiths this is it this is the last
battle in our coliseum themed
competition gladiator the forge
so good luck your time starts now my
game plan is to forge out this canister
cut the canister in half for the outer
jacket and then forge out a 20 layer
random pattern bullet have that as a
sandwich i'm setting up my sandmay and
so that there's already a gap after i
get this entire thing welded and
prepared to begin drying out my blade
after i get the axe head shaped out it's
time to go onto the pick this is not
your traditional pickaxe it's a recurve
pickaxe so i do that with my good old
trusty hand hammer and the anvil horn
jesse's blade is like a badass
now with the blade pretty much for to
shape it's time for the quench
there we go all right jesse has his axe
head quench
still has to get that pick done
boom jesse has a fully quenched blade
it's great it's a little bit heavy so
i can definitely spend a lot of time on
the grinder and make sure it's as light
as it needs to
be one of the parameters is a leather
wrap so it's time to give it some flair
i want it to look like a bloody mess
what is jesse doing it's trying to make
it look like it's bloodied up
how long does that stuff take to dry
long enough that i'm gonna have red
hands
this thing looks so menacing even my
hands look bloody
last thing i want to do is put an edge
on this thing
this time i go with 16 layers because
that's four less chances of affordable
not taking if i cut it up four times
i'll still have 64 layers total with
that 1095 core for the same line
all the forged bolts took so once i get
the length that i need i can cut it up
into four pieces stack it and draw it
out to get the 64 layers
good
now that i'm confident that the welds
are good i can draw it out and then
forge weld the sand my i see that some
of the welds around the eye are
splitting about a quarter of an inch i
drifted the eyeballs too thin and
there's a crack going right down it i
just want to do an edge quench on the
axe head because if there is too much
stress on that cracked weld around the
eye it could blow the entire weld apart
i'm hoping that this heat treat goes
well
[Music]
all right guys we got two bladesmiths
with two fully quenched weapons these
guys are seriously neck and neck yeah
the last time i lost against jesse it
was because of the handle so i'm going a
little extra on this one
gert's been spending a lot of time with
that handle
last challenge make it beautiful i
finally have everything put together and
i am extremely happy now hopefully my
weapon's good enough to beat jesse
five
four
three
two
one vice miss put down your tools this
round is over
ladder years of the forge
your delabras look evenly match but it's
time to find out what kind of lethal
damage they will do this is the kill
test
kurt
you're up first you ready for this i'm
ready all right let's do this
damn
all right kurt let's talk about your
delabra here first up
it is razor sharp that time is going to
have a headache for a long time now
using this on that ballistics dummy it
is amazing every thrust with your pick
here penetrated this because of the
balance you have here allows for a nice
thrust and delivery on that but during
the test
you lost a section right here
one of the layers from your blade right
here didn't weld all the way through but
looking at this
your core is still solid so it's still
gonna be a functional and testable blade
and overall sir
you're the labra
you'll kill
thank you doug jesse you ready
all right let's do this
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right jesse let's talk about your
labral here first up you have a heavier
blade here but it serves it very well
when you're doing damage like that the
feel of the weapon really allows it to
go deep into this but it's dummy overall
sir you're the labra
you'll heal
thank you
all right gentlemen you know what time
it is it's time for our strength test
the roman armor and shield chop
and kurt you are out first oh destroy it
i can't wait to
[Music]
[Music]
that was pretty cool
so kurt this is a good-looking weapon
the leather wrap you did and the
texturing up on the handle actually make
it quite comfortable to swing the issue
i have is this delamination it's come
further open
and didn't affect using it at all but i
do worry that
that that's going to continue to be a
problem
all right jesse you're up you ready
sure
all right jesse right off the bat great
look it's a good shape the pattern came
out really nice and where it really
stands out is right there on the socket
which is kind of cool you still got an
edge
everything's right and tight
everything's solid
all in all it held up beautifully great
job thank
you had fun didn't you
well jesse curt i couldn't have asked
for a better final match up
at the end of the day only one of you
can take home that final title and the
last check for five thousand dollars
the gladiator forge is
[Music]
jesse you are unstoppable
well kurt you should be proud of your
work but unfortunately deliberate did
not make the cut i'm gonna have to ask
you to please step off the forge floor
thank you gentlemen thank you kurt
christie congrats man you deserve it
thank you
so jesse took another title and i don't
disagree at all he once again turned in
an awesome weapon
kurt you did a good job man thank you
chen hi
well jesse i've got one word to describe
you and that is impressive you just won
your eighth glenda ford title and you
have 50 000 to take home with you
congratulations thank you
this experience was definitely once in a
lifetime i just want 50 grand
i'm planning on putting so much of it
into blade smoothing i already made a
spreadsheet of all the tools i'm gonna
buy i'll finally live the dream as
opposed to just dreaming the dream
you